what if Toyota had a commercial that
said like Prius the choice car for the
gay man of America would we would
everyone just like sell their car dude
people would leave them that
yeah everyone knows that's the Ford
Fiesta a seat contoured for your gay ass
[Music]
you guys know about the Bud Light
controversy right yeah yeah and right
now do you support you're no not is that
it's not the fact that they support
transgender but it's the fact that they
were like kind of forcing it down
people's throats of like you gotta
[__] like this campaign because you
because you're stupid rednecks or
whatever yeah you're stupid [__]
redneck idiots that's what this is
stupid rednecks why don't you like
transgenders hey why don't you take a
break from [__] your sister and go
get a cold one yeah
they're saying and and so there's a car
and they're just like actually
I don't have a problem about transgender
but if you put it that way that would
have been well received yeah yeah but so
it's so stupid there's a dust up about
that obviously
uh Bud Lights uh CEO has come out and
said that with all the talk on social
media about how Bud Light is [__]
you see like a bunch of fridges full of
Bud Light and people always taking
pictures of fridges full of Bud Light
they get all the coolers they're going
like see yeah everything is good I made
a change
um the Bud Light CEO says there's only
been a one percent drop in global sales
even though they're stocks Plumbing
there's tots [__] dropped like
billions of recovered already it kind of
did it kind of like a v-shaped recovery
people bought the dip dude
we have a lot of Alcoholics and a lot of
Alcoholics were just hooked on their
brand and in their they tried Coors and
they're just it's not the same and then
they had to go back to Bud Light I think
alcoholics drink PBR though yeah really
yeah because the cheapest Jeffrey Dahmer
drank it he did yeah and he was a
massive alcohol I'm not a huge fan of
PBR I'm not gonna lie really I love
Natty Ice
no I'm just kidding I almost threw up
saying that yeah
crickets crickets that is a bad dude but
I used to do a little hack when I went
to improv parties is I would not want to
drink Natty Ice but it was the cheapest
thing to bring you have to bring
something so I would bring Natty Ice in
a drink
cool hack and then you'd go who brought
this [__] let's bring it to [__]
daddy ice huh so that's the update that
it's just down one percent it's down one
percent and the um the CEO he's
basically reacting to the backlash
because there's a hell of coverage on
YouTube especially get won't go broke is
like the title of all these videos
Everyone loves this [__] right
um conservatives are basically saying
hold the line right hold the line like
we got them right where we want them
that's great
um I can't do it I miss my Bud Light
it's interesting though that they ended
up sort of being caught right in between
like because of that how there's like
conservatives are like oh you guys
[__] up but then Liberals are like you
haven't doubled down right so it's like
both sides are like upset yeah but
didn't they just
give them a lot of publicity and then
the people in the middle that just don't
give a [__] they're like I think a lot
of people really just don't give a [__]
just buy it exactly a ton of people do
not give a [__] yeah and even if you did
give a [__] a little bit you know I
can't believe they did that while you're
[__] drinking your Bud Light yeah and
you're just laughing about it like all
that they did that yeah I think it's
just interesting because it's like I
can't believe that guy's wearing a
[__] dress I'll never buy Bud Light
again
is that it you could make a squeeze it
bottle shaped like a dick I will chug
that thing yeah that's what Bud Light
should have done is they should have
made dick-shaped cans after that we ate
thick flavors chips here and then how do
you take yourself so seriously that
you're like I ain't drinking no dick
shape can
you know what I mean like that yeah then
Bud light's kind of like digging in on
it I will say though all the cans are
regular cans and there's one dick-shaped
can I don't know if I'm specifically
going for the dick-shaped camera speak
for yourself
you don't know that but we know you
better than you know when the salivation
starts you have to this is true their
campaign should have been their campaign
should have been RP are so good that
you'll suck a dick for it that's right
and then it's a dick shape oh that's
good Klondike bar right what would you
do for a Klondike card all right and the
guy's like I was straight but now I'm
gay because I wanted
and then and then at home you're like
damn I gotta try these clothes I don't
see what the hype is about I don't even
know I was a dessert guy and now I'm a
full raging homosexual I'm married to a
man
I've made you a minute not much of a
sweet tooth one snack like a shadow in
between meals snack but remember as a
kid though like Klondike bars like we
couldn't my mom didn't get them for us
like because it was gonna make you gay
or whatever yeah yeah probably but she
just was like nah you guys don't need
that junk but then the whole time you're
like [__] I want to know what the hype
what would you do for a contact bar
should we get some contacts huh they're
bombs I like the dark chocolate one they
are really good
what what's what I just love it dude I
love the idea that some guy just really
wants dessert and now he's made to a man
he's adopting kids yeah and he knew
mistake
he's like I'm gonna I gotta file a bunch
of paperwork
the only way he can get Klondike bar I
could force my wife I'd even buy it yeah
dude he won't buy it I gotta contact
this U.S census
like I don't know a gay dude lives in
this house
what would you do for a comeback boy but
he's just like I just want to know what
the chocolate vanilla or like
the chocolate coating my wife said no
dessert it's the perfect square there's
just too much about this that's funny so
it's hard to take anything it's hard to
take anyone's rage seriously I don't
understand getting pissed about this I
literally do I've tried to put myself
there it's like what are you really mad
about the only thing that's dumb is the
fact that it that it was a big Panda
move but everything is in Market exactly
what's not you know maybe that's it you
really like deep down your hearts of
heart so you love Bud Light and then you
saw that commercial
piece of [__] is getting fired up it's a
Tim Robinson sketch you're like what the
[__] and then for like two weeks you're
just like you're complaining about it
you're talking talking about it but then
when in your like when you're alone time
you're just like [__]
[__] like we want a Bud Light what if
Toyota has a commercial that said like
Prius the choice car for the gay man of
America
would everyone just like sell their car
dude people would leave them that would
be hilarious though
everyone knows that's the Ford Fiesta a
seat contoured for your gas
let me just go oh I guess it is
you're not gonna duel and seats are a
little different yeah you got a rear
view mirror to look at your
boyfriend's in the back seat
you're gonna be in the backseat too huh
voice recognition that will recognize
your list
I'm so dumb uh do you guys remember when
uh Balenciaga did that campaign and they
had like oh the child stuff yeah the
child stuff and then afterwards people
started like taking their Balenciaga and
like throwing it out or like burning it
or random [__] like that now they're out
fifteen hundred dollars
the kind of societal response via social
media to like stand buy something
because it's such a
I don't know it's such an individual
Choice sometimes you know what I mean
like I wish I can understand again if
brand for real was like
explicitly about like child labor or
sexualization then you're like okay well
this is not a good look but even if
somebody like Toyota was like Prius is
like the the choice for gay people
everywhere and you had a Prius yeah it's
like it would be so impractical to be
like dude I'm hetero so I can't drive
this car anymore you know what I mean
it's such a I don't think I don't think
that's true I think you would have to
sell it if you're a hetero dude
it might be more expensive because all
the gays want to buy it that's true
the value I've always wanted if
something's made for gays and you know
it's good yeah the idea that like before
right so before they did they do these
commercials with American flags and
Clydesdales and for Bud Light and [__]
yeah and like the idea that like I'm a
truck driver or something and I'm
watching that [__] and I'm just [__]
[__] yeah brother
I know I'm being sold to it all time so
I don't know why people just get all
[__] exactly they were doing it prior
yeah yeah but you know what's funny
though too is like okay it's one thing
to be
like okay I'm a big fan of Bud Light
they did this I'm mad at them I'm not
gonna drink their beer but then it's
another level if you're like a guy like
say Kid Rock right this dude puts out
his [__] bud light on a table and
then let's start shooting it up and then
he posts that he films that post that
put it on his Instagram you're like dude
you're a grown ass man like what the
[__] are you doing taking a video of
yourself shooting up a whole bunch of
Bud Light and then putting on Instagram
I think I think for him it's it's kind
of like if you're fandom already thinks
that way then you're really preaching to
the choir and riling them up like that's
your people you think this is Kid Rock's
fault on the on on the conservative side
he has to call him texting that one song
and I want to be a cowboy
so I always refer to him as text as
white white knowledge yeah dude I gotta
listen more Kid Rock what do you know
about Kid Rock absolutely nothing I do
not like any Limp Biscuit facts right
he's more of like a rap country guy yeah
yeah I mean he was he was previously of
straight up rapper
yeah in the 90s he had a flat top and
was just all rap yeah that he integrated
that with this guy I know because I had
his rap card
the idea that I'm walking down like a
New York City street and I see a guy
dressed like a ballerina and I'm like
you're shaking your pissed out I can't
get there yeah I can't get there I'm
sorry not yet maybe I need to watch more
propaganda yeah yeah would you flip out
if if um like what if you like Capri
Suns like what if they had to stop Asian
hate flavor
did you lose your [__] stop what would
the flavor be though
it tastes like egg rolls Nations
hate on your taste buds
what do you think of that how's you know
what I think I don't really respond well
to like marketing campaigns but I think
I'd respond well to that
I think I might I might get some buy-in
from me I don't think it's gonna make
Capri Sun taste any different
like it already tastes like that too
it already tastes like it's stopping
Asian egg
yeah it still tastes the same it doesn't
matter what cause it has yeah
especially if I'm a frequent user of
Capri Suns yeah I'm still buying dude
I'm picking up what they're set one
[Music]